[Music]
it's that time of the month again yet
this time things have changed
playstation plus is now split into three
tiers and today it's all about the free
games we get as playstation plus
essential subscribers that's gonna take
time to get used to this tier now gives
us at least two games a month and this
time there's three so let's do this on
the ps4 and ps5 is crash bandicoot it's
about time the iconic platformer is back
as we are sent to gather the quantum
masks to prevent neocortex from taking
over the multiverse crash 4 mixes up the
old formula by adding new mechanics like
wall running and rail skating but it's
the addition of other characters that
really sets this one apart toner has a
grapple hook for combat and grabbing
boxes that are seemingly impossible to
reach neocortex has a dash mechanic and
a ray gun for battles and the slow dingo
dial has a vacuum to turn crates into
weapons even with the addition of all
these combat related items timing your
jumps remains key to progression and
although the difficulty level is lower
there are flashback missions and mirror
modes for those who like to experience
crash punishment the main reason the
game feels more forgiving is thanks to
one thing there's a shadow under crash
the days of guessing where your
character is are gone reviewers mostly
love crash four with the average score
eight out of ten also on the ps4 is the
dark pictures man of medan i guess we'd
class this as an interactive drama as
the story plays out before us and we
impact that story by making key
decisions man of madan is made by the
same team that brought us until dawn yet
this time it's much more serious than
its predecessor the greatest part of
these games is that each decision has
consequence and two playthroughs of the
same story can yield very different
cutscenes and endings i have to admit
the first 90 minutes of mana madan are
cripplingly slow but it does get better
if you stick around long enough there
are many ways to unalive the heroes of
the story and there's lots of gore so
prepare yourself if you're a little
squeamish one of the most impressive
parts at least to me is the online game
mode jump in with a friend and take
control of a character each and try to
survive your paths cross constantly and
your actions affect what they see do you
team up and coordinate an attack or
completely ignore your teammates the
result can be hilarious and it's much
less scary when you play with a friend
review scores are all over the place for
the dark pictures series 7 out of 10 was
the most consistent i found for man of
madan and our third game for july is
arcade geddon a stylized multiplayer
shooter set in third person our local
arcade has made a super game combining
all the best games in the world into one
but it's been hacked and a virus is
spreading inside you can go alone or
with up to three friends to jump in and
save the day the game is split into
different biomes which are procedurally
generated so every time you do jump in
it should feel different the plan for
arcadergedon is to house different game
modes over time but at its core it's a
pve survival horde mode we pick up
missions from vendors and jump into the
game to complete them rinse and repeat
it's sort of like a roguelike every time
you jump back in everything you had on a
previous run is totally gone over the
last 12 months new biomes weapons and
bosses have been added as well as many
pvp modes for those who don't want to
game against endless ai arguably the pvp
minigames are better than the core mode
illfonic regularly updates the roadmap
for arcade again and more modes are
coming on release so the question is
will you try it so that's our month
those on ps plus extra i'm trying to
decide how to cover that content stray
will be the first day-and-date release
coming to that tier later this month
depending on how regularly that tier is
updated i'll showcase new arrivals in
another video i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]